La lettre de la liberté
Nous sommes ici en train de considérer la lettre de la liberté
ou la lettre d'émancipation du christianisme et du chrétien.
L'objectif de cette lettre c'était de protéger l'Église d'être vue,
même les christianistes d'être vues tout simplement comme une secte
qui a divergé du judaïsme mais qui a tissu du judaïsme.
Et donc les mouvements, je vous rappelle, étaient Paul qui a implanté ses églises en Asie mineure.
Un petit peu après, des personnes qui venaient d'entre les juifs sont arrivées à cette église,
des faux maîtres, des maîtres qui s'autoproclamaient apôtres dans un certain sens
en tant qu'envoyés de la part de l'église de Jérusalem
et qui mettaient en question l'autorité de l'apôtre Paul.
Pour conduire cette église qui avait compris l'évangile,
l'église majoritairement formée par des païens, des non-chrétiens,
ceux qui n'étaient pas issus du contexte culturel ni religieux juif.
Et donc eux qui étaient païens avaient compris l'évangile de Jésus-Christ,
les saluent par la grâce, par la foi,
et qui étaient contents, qui étaient dans la joie,
mais qui par l'influence de ces hommes-là,
de ces faux maîtres, de ces faux apôtres,
ils étaient encouragés à revenir en arrière,
et ils étaient même au bord de ces circoncires,
de ces fers circoncires.
Quand on considère toutes les conséquences et tous les risques
qui s'est-là impliqués, surtout dans cette génération,
dans les premiers siècles,
médicalement parlant,
de faire une telle chirurgie dans les adultes,
c'était déjà quelque chose de très risqué,
mais ils étaient prêts à se soumettre,
même à ce type de pratique-là,
sous la pression de croire que Jésus-Christ n'était pas suffisant
pour leur salut,
mais il fallait bien sûr que Jésus-Christ fasse son œuvre,
qu'il soit leur moyen de justification devant Dieu,
ok, donc ils croyaient que Jésus-Christ est venu vivre la vie parfaite pour nous,
mourir à la croix pour nous,
mais ils ont pensé qu'il fallait encore quelque chose d'autre
à cause de l'influence du peuple juif.
Donc ce peuple juif disait,
vous savez, si vous marchez dans la direction des dieux, c'est bien,
vous avez reçu les Christes tout comme nous avons reçu les Christes,
donc c'était des juifs chrétiens,
mais on va comprendre qu'ils n'étaient pas des vrais chrétiens,
mais ils disaient,
là, une fois que vous êtes sauvés,
si vous voulez vraiment être considérés comme des enfants des dieux,
si vous voulez garder un statut comme celui des juifs,
vous devez vous faire circoncire,
et si vous voulez être plus efficace dans votre sanctification,
vous devez suivre la loi d'Israël.
Donc c'est pour ça qu'ils ont été appelés des judaïsants,
ils ont voulu rajouter à l'œuvre parfaite du Christ
quelque chose qui était plutôt élémentaire
serrés dans les passés jusqu'à ce qui Christ arrive,
et maintenant ils veulent revenir en arrière.
Donc c'était la pression,
et marcher de cette manière,
la problématique vécue chez les Galates,
c'était mettre en question l'autorité de l'apôtre et Paul,
l'accusation était plus ou moins comme celle-ci,
vous voyez, Paul n'était pas avec les douze
pendant les ministères du Christ sans vie.
Donc les vrais apôtres, ce sont ceux issus de Jérusalem,
ce n'est pas la première fois que la problématique apostolique apparaît dans l'histoire.
Les problèmes, c'était les problèmes primaires d'autorité.
Vous ne devez pas écouter Paul,
vous devez, ok, écouter Paul dans une certaine mesure,
mais vous devez reconnaître qu'il y a une autorité supérieure,
et nous sommes envoyés par cette autorité supérieure,
l'église de Jérusalem.
Et donc eux, ils se disaient apôtres.
Et donc c'est pour ça que Paul, dans sa lettre,
il va aborder un thème central,
qui c'est décrire la nature de la justification par la foi,
avec l'objectif de démontrer que la justification par la foi
ne fonctionne pas que pour notre salut,
c'est-à-dire pour que Dieu nous pardonne de nos fautes,
pour que Dieu enlève notre coupabilité,
mais que la justification par la foi en soi-même est suffisante aussi
pour déclencher dans une sanctification efficace.
Donc nous n'avons pas besoin d'aucune chose à part la compréhension
de cette œuvre merveilleuse par laquelle Dieu nous justifie
par la foi dans l'œuvre parfaite de Jésus-Christ.
Et c'est là non seulement pour nous délivrer
de la juste colère des dieux
qui allait retomber sur nous
dans les justes jugements des dieux,
elle va nous délivrer de cette coupabilité,
mais elle va nous délivrer également
de la force ou la puissance du péché.
Nous sommes affranchis
de la coupabilité du péché,
mais nous sommes affranchis de la puissance du péché.
Nous allons progresser en sanctification
comme conséquence
de la justification par la foi.
Et donc Paul, il est en train de,
non seulement de communiquer,
c'est pour la liberté que Christ vous a affranchie,
ce qu'il est en train de dire,
c'est qu'il vous a affranchis au moment de votre conversion,
vous avez été délivré du jugement,
mais c'est pour la liberté,
ce n'est pas pour revenir en arrière
et être enchaîné par toutes ces emphases judaïsantes.
Donc c'est pour la liberté
et non pour l'esclavage,
à nouveau des rudiments élémentaires de ces mondes.
Ce n'est pas pour que vous soyez encore plus névrotique
après votre conversion,
sans savoir si vous êtes sauvé maintenant ou non,
si vous allez perdre votre salut à n'importe quel moment,
c'est de se reposer.
Cette œuvre a été parfaite,
si vous avez été vraiment affranchis,
vous êtes affranchis pour toujours.
Et ça, c'est plus efficace pour votre sanctification.
Mais, donc, les thèmes centrales,
c'est la justification par la foi,
mais en même temps,
il doit commencer par la défense de son autorité en tant qu'apôtre.
Ce qu'il vise à faire,
ce n'est pas pour s'émettre dans la position la plus importante,
c'est plutôt pour qu'on soit sûr
que son message est un message
qu'on doit croire,
qu'on peut faire confiance,
on doit être sûr que son message est un message divin.
Et donc, par là, bien sûr,
qu'il va répondre à ses accusations
en démontrant qu'il n'y a aucune chose en lui
qui puisse les diminuer devant les autres apôtres,
mais il va remarquer quand même
que son appel était, d'une certaine manière,
encore plus spécial que les leurs.
Là, il ne veut pas se mettre au-dessus des autres apôtres,
il veut juste dire,
nous sommes avec les mêmes messages,
avec les mêmes appels d'origine divine,
mais ne pensez pas qu'il n'y a aucune chose en moi
qui soit moins importante qu'il y ait chez eux.
Donc ça, c'est la structure de la lettre,
comme on a vu,
et nous avons commencé à considérer la salutation.
Dans la salutation,
c'est clair pour nous tous
qu'Paul est, dès le départ,
en train de mettre en lumière
l'importance de son autorité apostolique.
Mais même dans la salutation,
nous voyons plus ou moins
l'ensemble de ces trois thèmes principaux de la lettre.
Et bien sûr qu'il est plus important
dans cette première section,
c'est notamment la défense de son apostolat.
Et donc, ce qui est important à remarquer,
et c'est là où nous nous sommes arrêtés,
c'est que même si au verset 1,
suivez avec moi,
Paul est juste ensuite apôtre,
non de la part des hommes,
ni par un homme,
mais par Jésus-Christ,
et Dieu le Père,
qu'il a ressuscité des morts.
Donc ici, nous voyons clairement,
c'est comme si Paul faisait
la référence minimale
à son propre nom
pour passer à l'emphase centrale
de cette première section,
c'est défendre mon apostolat.
Ce qui importe par rapport à moi
dans cette affaire,
c'est que vous considérez
que je ne suis rien
personnellement vis-à-vis
à cette vocation.
Et en même temps,
c'est une omission fonctionnelle,
si on peut dire comme ça,
il a un objectif
pour passer vite
à cette notion d'apôtre.
Et c'est une option très parlante,
surprenante,
mais très parlante.
Pourquoi ?
Et donc,
je vous présente deux raisons,
car nous pouvons comprendre
encore mieux
la nature
de cette vocation apostolique
de Paul
à la lumière
de la grandeur de Paul.
C'est comme si Paul
était en train de dire
celui-ci.
Donc, Paul,
il était déjà connu
de cette église,
et donc ça nous donnerait
aussi l'opportunité
de mieux connaître Paul
comme cette église
le connaissait,
pour mieux comprendre,
ça l'est.
OK.
Mais plus que ça,
c'est malgré
la grandeur
de Paul
en tant qu'homme naturel,
sa vocation
en tant qu'apôtre,
c'est comme si il disait,
j'ai toutes ces capacités,
j'ai toute cette formation,
tout cet historique,
mais je ne pourrai
rien faire
pour me sauver,
pour sauver personne,
pour la gloire de Dieu.
Donc,
c'est qu'il est en train
de dire,
je peux être
une personne spéciale,
mais comparativement
à l'œuvre de Dieu
dans ma vie
et ma vocation
en tant qu'apôtre,
je ne suis rien.
C'est très important.
Et en même temps,
ça nous aide,
et là c'est intéressant
et c'est très important
pour ça,
ça nous aide à comprendre
que le fait
qu'il soit un apôtre
ne supprime pas
son historique,
sa personnalité
et ses capacités.
Donc,
les dimanches derniers,
nous nous sommes arrêtés
dans la considération
de qui était Paul,
l'homme naturel,
pour comprendre
combien infiniment
plus sublime
était sa vocation apostolique,
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
que nous sommes
l'un des hommes
les plus importants,
l'un des cerveaux
les plus brillants
de toute l'histoire
de l'humanité,
indépendamment
de sa conversion,
quelque part.
Et au même temps,
Paul,
il était lui-même
très conscient
que pendant toute
sa vie passée,
toute sa formation,
des choses
qu'il n'a pas choisies,
la famille dans laquelle
il est né,
les opportunités
qu'il a eues
pour étudier,
toute sa formation,
toutes ses capacités
personnelles
ont été déjà
l'œuvre des dieux.
C'était l'œuvre
de la grâce
souveraine des dieux.
Il était responsable
dans tout ça,
il a saisi
ses opportunités,
il a employé
ses efforts,
mais son caractère,
sa diligence,
ses capacités,
couplées aux circonstances
et aux opportunités,
étaient une œuvre
des dieux.
C'est pour ça
qu'au verset 13
du chapitre 1,
Paul va dire
« Vous avez d'ailleurs
entendu parler
des mon comportement
autrefois,
dans les judaïsmes,
j'ai persécuté
à outrance
l'église des dieux,
j'ai cherché
à la détruire
et j'étais plus avancé
dans les judaïsmes
que beaucoup
de ceux
de mon âge
parmi mon peuple
car j'ai été animé
dans elle
excessive
pour les traditions
de mes ancêtres. »
Donc,
ce que Paul
est en train
de dire ici,
c'est qu'il a pris
conscience
de son passé,
de sa vie
et ensuite
il va dire
« Mais quand il a plu
à celui qui m'a séparé
dès les seins
de ma mère
de révéler son fils
à moi
afin que j'annonçasse
l'évangile
aux gentils,
aux païens. »
Donc,
ce qu'il peut
être en train
de dire pour nous ici,
c'est que
« Ok,
tous mes efforts,
tous mes privilèges,
toutes mes capacités,
par mes propres efforts,
même si j'ai voulu
sincèrement
arriver à Dieu,
je suis arrivé
à devenir
un persécuteur.
Je ne pouvais pas
me sauver,
je ne pouvais rien faire. »
Et au même temps,
il avait conscience
que Dieu l'avait séparé
dès les seins de sa mère
pour qu'il traverse
tous ses épisodes,
y compris les traumas
de ses péchés,
les péchés si graves
de persécuter
l'Église du Christ.
Et toutes ces choses-là
étaient à service
de sa formation.
Il a été forgé
par Dieu
avant sa conversion
pour qu'après sa conversion,
il accomplisse sa mission.
C'est l'emphase
qu'on a considérée
les dimanches derniers.
On considère donc par là
que Paul,
il est l'un des plus grands trophées
s'il n'est pas
les plus grands trophées
de la grâce divine
que le monde
n'a jamais connue.
Et donc,
ça nous a donné
la compréhension
des deux choses principales.
Quand on regarde
en arrière
dans nos vies,
nous pouvons
trouver du réconfort
car la grâce
souveraine des dieux
était en train
de nous préparer
pour accomplir
les choses
que personne ne va
pouvoir accomplir
à part nous-mêmes.
c'est l'œuvre
des dieux
et je dois
trouver en dieux
cette signification.
Et en même temps,
nous devons être
conscients
et responsables
de ce qui nous sommes
et des choses
que nous puissions faire
pour nous engager
avec diligence
surtout après la conversion
à accomplir quelque chose
que personne d'autre
ne peut les faire.
Et donc,
on a considéré
qu'Paul est
l'homme naturel
en tant qu'homme naturel
et un chef d'œuvre
de la grâce prévenante
des dieux.
C'est-à-dire,
quand on voit
ce qui Paul est devenu
!
avant sa conversion,
même s'il n'était pas converti,
comme je vous ai dit,
il serait l'un des hommes
les plus importants
de l'histoire.
Et ça,
c'est reconnu
même par les laïcs.
Et donc,
on a considéré
plusieurs aspects
de la vie de Paul,
de la formation de Paul,
les circonstances,
tempérament,
caractère,
capacité,
diligence,
excellence
dans les cultures
grecques,
romaines,
hébraïques.
Et on a compris
donc que Paul,
il a été excellent
dans tout ce qu'il faisait.
Mais quand il faisait
de cette vie
et de son curriculum
ses priorités,
malheureusement,
il est arrivé
à la persécution
de l'Église.
Paul,
il était,
première chose
qu'on a vu,
un chef d'œuvre
de la grâce
préparatoire de Dieu.
Deuxième chose
qu'on a vu,
c'est que Paul,
en tant qu'homme naturel,
est un trophée
de la grâce
salvatrice des dieux.
C'est-à-dire,
cette grâce préparatoire,
pour plus proche
qu'il était
de la vraie religion,
du judaïsme,
en étant très sage,
d'avoir une famille
quelque part religieuse,
dans la vraie religion,
quelque part,
tout cela n'a pas été
suffisant
pour sa conversion.
Il était en opposition
à l'aboutissement
vrai de la vraie religion,
il était en opposition
à Christ lui-même,
et sa rencontre
avec Jésus
se passe
lorsqu'il est en train
de persécuter l'Église.
Par là,
on a considéré
qu'il était un trophée
de la grâce
salvatrice
de Jésus-Christ.
Et là,
c'est très important,
car, attention,
les implications
de tout cela
pour notre compréhension
de la lettre,
c'est que Paul,
il avait conscience
que ce qui lui a sauvé
n'étaient pas
les œuvres de judaïsme.
Ce qui l'a sanctifié
n'étaient pas
les systèmes judaïques.
Il était lui-même,
il était lui-même
un trophée
de la grâce
salvatrice des dieux.
Lorsqu'il était
en pleine opposition
à l'Église,
la loi n'a pu
rien faire pour lui.
Sa circoncision
n'a pas pu
rien faire pour lui.
Et donc là,
il est en train
par expérience
personnelle
de défendre
la vérité
de la justification
par la foi.
Et plus que ça,
cette capacité
sanctificatrice,
si on peut dire
comme ça,
cette capacité
de cette expérience
de conversion
avec Jésus
pour nous sauver.
Et c'est le troisième point
que nous allons considérer
aujourd'hui.
Et donc,
Paul était
un trophée
en chef d'œuvre
de la grâce
préparatoire des dieux
avant sa conversion.
Il était un trophée
de la grâce
salvatrice des dieux.
Et aujourd'hui,
nous allons considérer
que Paul était
en tant qu'homme
chrétien,
un modèle
de coopération
avec la grâce
rédemptrice
du Saint-Esprit.
Pourquoi je suis en train
de m'arrêter là
et de prendre
considération
de tout ça ?
Je vais vous expliquer.
C'est très important,
comme nous allons voir
par la suite,
que le fait
que Paul soit
un apôtre
suggère,
implique
qu'il a
certaines choses
qu'il a pu vivre,
il y a certaines capacités
qu'il a reçues,
certains dons
qui vont les détacher
de tous les autres
êtres humains.
Il y a des choses
qui sont exclusives
à sa vocation
particulière
en tant qu'apôtre.
Sauf que quand on
met l'emphase
prioritairement
sur cet aspect
ou de manière
exagérée
sur cet aspect,
nous pouvons vite
tomber
dans l'erreur catholique
de développer
une conception
de l'apôtre
ou des apôtres
comme cette conception
canonique
des saints.
Et bien sûr
que la Bible
nous appelle
tous saints,
nous sommes séparés
par Dieu
du monde
et pour lui,
pour nous sanctifier.
Paul va appeler
les membres
de toutes les églises
auxquelles il va écrire
100.
Mais la réalité
c'est que quand on commence
à développer
une vision
très idéaliste,
très lointaine
de ces hommes,
de ces douze,
nous pouvons avoir
l'impression
que ce qu'ils font
nous ne pouvons pas faire.
Et dans certains aspects,
c'est vrai.
Mais la réalité
c'est que
quand on garde
tous les indices
bibliques
qui nous démontrent
que ces hommes-là
ont été
quelque part
élevés
à une statue
inaccessible
pour nous
par rapport
à certains aspects,
ils ont été
quand même
l'œuvre
de Dieu,
ils étaient
engagés
dans leurs efforts,
dans leurs capacités
conscientes
de leur vocation.
C'est un exercice,
c'est très important,
c'était un exercice
aussi,
si je peux dire
comme ça,
logique.
par exemple,
Paul,
il va voir
ce qu'il était avant,
il va considérer
cette expérience
puissante
qu'il a eue
avec Dieu
et il va se dire
à la lumière
des mécapacités,
de ce que je suis,
quels seraient
les meilleurs emplois
des mécapacités.
Et par là,
il peut comprendre
en fait
que Dieu était
en train de lui
préparer
pour être apôtre,
mais cela va traverser
cet exercice
raisonnable
de présenter son corps
comme un culte
agréable à Dieu,
comme un sacrifice
en reconnaissant
quelles sont mes capacités
où je vais me mettre
dans la promotion
de l'évangile.
Comment je peux comprendre
de manière plus spécifique
quelle est ma vocation ?
Cela passe aussi
par un exercice raisonnable.
Voilà,
l'Église atteste
mes capacités,
les personnes sont bénies
par ma vie
en tant que modèle de foi,
je considère
toutes les capacités
que Dieu m'a données
jusqu'ici,
je suis redé
devant lui,
il m'a acquis par prix,
qu'est-ce que je vais faire
dans ma vie ?
Est-ce que je vais rester
tout simplement
en train de faire
des choses
qui peuvent être
assez médiocres
par rapport
à mes capacités ?
Ou est-ce que je vais
prendre mon histoire
comme l'histoire
des dieux
et de voir
quelle est la meilleure
manière d'utiliser ma vie ?
Et donc,
c'est cet exercice-là
qui passe par
l'exercice logique
mais aussi par
l'expérience spirituelle.
car Paul,
il s'est voyé
à partir du moment
de sa conversion,
l'étendue
de la grâce
des dieux sur lui,
la profondeur
de la grâce
des dieux pour celui
quand il s'évoit
comme persécuteur
de l'église
et que maintenant,
la grâce
a surabondé sur lui,
il est motivé aussi
par expérience personnelle,
il ne peut pas
faire autre chose.
Et donc,
bien sûr,
que cet appel
est un appel
spécial,
exclusif
dans certains aspects,
celui de Paul,
mais en même temps,
il est en parfaite harmonie
avec l'œuvre
que Dieu était déjà
en train de faire
dans sa vie.
Et donc,
il y a
une participation
des Paul
dans cette coopération
avec la grâce des dieux.
Donc,
on va bientôt,
à partir du dimanche prochain,
nous plonger
sur les aspects
exclusifs
de la vocation apostolique.
Mais je veux encore
considérer
comment Paul
a été conscient
et combien
il a employé
ses efforts
pour coopérer
avec la grâce
rédemptrice
du Saint-Esprit.
Quand je dis
grâce rédemptrice
du Saint-Esprit,
les termes rédemption
dans la Bible,
c'est lié
à la notion
d'être racheté
et ça parle
d'avoir payé
un prix
pour acquérir
un esclave,
par exemple,
pour la franchir.
OK ?
Et notamment,
lorsqu'il a mis
toute cette emphase-là
entre la relation
du Christ
avec l'Église,
comme si l'Église
était rachetée
par lui,
c'est comme si
cette église
par laquelle
Dieu a mis
son affection,
Christ a mis
elle était esclave.
Et lui,
donc,
il va se rébaisser,
traverser tout
ce qu'il faut
pour payer les prix
afin de la franchir
aussi.
Et donc,
ce qui est intéressant,
c'est de considérer
que les termes rédemption,
il parle beaucoup
sur les prix payés,
mais je voulais
mettre l'emphase ici
sur l'aspect
plus large
de la rédemption.
C'est cette œuvre
qui Dieu fait en nous,
non tout simplement
pour nous délivrer
et nous abandonner,
ou comme par exemple,
c'est qu'il peut la faire
dans la résurrection
de Lazare,
il dit,
viens en dehors,
et après,
il a envoyé les personnes
pour enlever
ses bandages.
C'est assez important,
donc l'œuvre de Dieu
ne s'arrête jamais,
tout simplement,
je vais ressusciter Lazare
et je vais le laisser
là,
avec
cette odeur
mauvaise,
avec ces bandages-là,
non,
on va faire un travail
de restauration.
Donc,
par là,
Paul,
il a coopéré
de manière
diligente
avec la grâce
rédemptrice
de Dieu.
Il était,
donc,
cet homme chrétien,
ok,
nouveau-né,
qui a regardé
sa vie en arrière,
qui a exercé
cet exercice raisonnable
par rapport à sa vie,
qui s'est consacré
et qui a coopéré
avec la grâce
du Saint-Esprit.
Voilà pourquoi
Paul a été
si réussi
dans tous les principaux fronts
dans lesquels
nous voyons
les succès
de la grâce
légère de sa vie.
Il a coopéré
avec le Saint-Esprit
dans cette œuvre
de restauration.
Et je voulais vous proposer
trois heures principales
par lesquelles
nous voyons
comment Paul
a coopéré
avec la grâce
rédemptrice
du Saint-Esprit.
Bien sûr
que ces choses
touchent sa vocation
spécifique
en tant qu'apôtre,
mais certes
des modèles
pour nous tous aussi.
Comme l'a dit Nat
au début,
et c'est vraiment
quelque chose
de très précis
et lié
à notre étude
aujourd'hui,
il y a certaines choses
que les apôtres
feront
qui sont exclusives,
mais les apôtres
à la fin
sont les modèles,
si on peut dire comme ça,
les plus élevés
pour la vie
de tous les chrétiens.
Nous allons voir
par exemple
qu'Étienne,
quand on regarde
et compare
la piété
d'Étienne,
son service,
son martyr
et qu'on compare
Étienne
avec certains des apôtres,
nous pouvons arriver
à la conclusion
qu'il était peut-être
plus rempli
du Saint-Esprit
que les autres.
Il était peut-être
plus connaisseur
par une intimité
de Jésus-Christ
car son témoignage
a été incroyable.
Donc,
il n'était pas un apôtre,
mais c'était quelqu'un
qui était là
avec une grande évidence.
Donc,
ce qui seront les apôtres,
ce seront les exemples,
les modèles les plus élevés
quelque part
pour ce que Dieu
va faire dans la vie
de nous tous.
Et la réalité,
c'est que quand on met
l'emphase sur la coopération
des pôles
en tant qu'homme chrétien,
dans l'œuvre des dieux
dans sa vie,
c'est plutôt pour que nous
soyons aussi diligents
dans ces ères-là.
Donc,
la première ère
dont je voulais
mettre l'emphase,
c'est Paul,
modèle des coopérations
avec l'œuvre
rédemptrice
du Saint-Esprit
en tant
qu'est théologien.
C'est très important,
c'est l'une des choses
qui vont ressortir
les plus
des contributions
de l'apôtre Paul
dans l'histoire
et c'est l'une des ères
les plus importantes
pour sa vie.
Donc,
je parle théologien,
je parle
sa connaissance
de Dieu
avec la précision
des termes
ou avec la précision
des connaissances.
Donc,
pour Achilles,
il a déjà dit ça,
nous sommes peut-être
dans la génération
des chrétiens
où nous pratiquons
l'idolâtrie
au sein de l'Église.
Et c'est quoi
l'idolâtrie ?
C'est
d'adorer
d'autres dieux
au lieu d'adorer
les seuls vrais dieux.
Et nous pouvons
adorer d'autres dieux
même en faisant
usage du nom
du vrai dieux.
Car de dire
Jésus
ou Dieu
sans avoir
une compréhension
de qui est Dieu
et qui est Jésus
selon les Écritures,
c'est d'inventer
un autre dieux
et d'adorer
qui est plutôt
formé par
notre imagination.
Et parfois,
on entend les personnes
dire comme ça,
non,
ces messages-là
à propos
de la colère
des dieux,
ce n'est pas
les dieux
comme je les crois.
Ce n'est pas
mon dieu,
ce n'est pas
mon Jésus.
Mon Jésus,
il est
infiniment plus
tolérant
que ce qu'il dit
ces pasteurs-là.
Mais la question,
c'est,
est-ce que ce que
ces pasteurs
dit est biblique ?
Est-ce que la description
qu'il est en train
de faire des dieux
est biblique ?
Et donc,
le problème,
c'est que moi,
je suis un idolâtre
et que je ne suis pas
en train de vouloir
accepter la vérité
à propos des dieux.
Et la seule conception
de Dieu qui sauve,
c'est la conception biblique.
Quand on parle
des théologies,
nous avons tous
des théologies.
Nous sommes tous
des théologiens.
D'ailleurs,
je vous encourage
à nouveau
car à cette conférence,
nous allons distribuer
par la première fois
ces livres d'Arcis Pro
qui,
nous sommes tous
des théologiens.
Et là,
il va expliquer
cette réalité.
Même les athées,
ils sont arrivés
à une décision là.
Ils ont choisi
une religion,
un Dieu pour eux.
Et la réalité,
c'est que nous sommes
tous des théologiens.
La grande question,
c'est combien précis
nous sommes par rapport
au seul et vrai Dieu.
Et quand on parle
que Paul était
en train de coopérer
avec sa formation
théologique,
c'est très important.
Bien sûr,
en tant qu'apôtre,
il a eu
une notion
qui ne permettait pas
qu'il commette
des erreurs
lorsqu'il allait
rédiger
ces termes
ou ces descriptions
des dieux,
de l'œuvre des dieux,
du Christ,
etc.
Donc,
la théologie
des Paul
pour parler
de l'inspiration
des Écritures,
pour parler
de la nature
des dieux,
pour parler
de la double nature
du Christ,
pour parler
de la Trinité
ou pour parler
de l'œuvre
du Christ
dans nos vies,
des ministères
du Saint-Esprit,
etc.
Toutes les descriptions
de l'être
et de l'œuvre
des dieux
que Paul nous a laissé
enregistrer dans la Bible
sont inhérentes.
Ça,
c'est un saut
apostolique.
Mais cela ne veut pas
indiquer
ni impliquer
que Paul n'était pas
en train de s'exercer
dans sa compréhension
biblique,
des dieux.
C'est très important
de remarquer
que nous pouvons même,
les théologiens,
les spécialistes
vont remarquer qu'il y a
un développement
naturel.
Quand on voit,
par exemple,
le Galaxe
et qu'on compare
avec ces autres lettres,
dans toutes les lettres
des Paul,
pour plus récentes
qu'elles soient
dans l'histoire,
pour plus anciennes
qu'elles soient,
nous trouvons
des enregistrements
inhérents.
Parfait,
excellent.
Et au même temps,
le développement
des conceptions,
la précision,
l'explication,
nous allons voir
qu'au fur et à mesure,
chaque nouvelle lettre
va rajouter quelque chose.
Donc,
c'est parfait
dans chaque étape,
mais c'est progressif
quelque part
dans les touts.
Et nous voyons
la même chose
chez les apôtres.
Les autres apôtres,
quand on pense
à Pierre,
à Thomas,
Thomas a été
corrigé quelque part
par rapport
à sa théologie.
Pierre a été aussi
corrigé par rapport
à sa théologie.
Juste après avoir
fait cette déclaration
incroyable
chez les Christ
et fils de Dieu vivant,
Jésus,
un peu après,
va dire,
arrière-moi,
Satan,
car tu penses
aux choses
de ces mondes.
C'est-à-dire,
jusqu'ici,
un grand éloge
à Pierre,
bienheureusement,
Simon,
fils de Jonas,
c'est ni charnissin
qui t'ont révélé ça.
Mais juste après,
ses pensées
étaient terrestres.
Il voulait,
lorsque Jésus parlait
du fait qu'il allait
devoir mourir
et ressusciter,
Pierre ne voulait pas
voir Jésus souffrir.
Et donc,
sa théologie
a été impactée
quelque part
par son attachement
à ces mondes.
et là,
Jésus va corriger Pierre.
Donc,
nous voyons
qu'il y a de l'espace
pour les développements
théologiques,
même des apôtres,
car ils étaient
aussi des êtres humains
qui étaient là
en train de se développer.
Et donc,
nous pouvons penser
à tous les apôtres,
là,
à l'épisode
de Marc,
chapitre 8,
où nous voyons,
par exemple,
Jésus qui va dire
à ses disciples
qui étaient avec lui
depuis longtemps déjà,
presque deux ans déjà
avec lui,
et ils avaient encore
l'influence
des traditions juives
dans leur compréhension
de la théologie.
Et Jésus va les reprocher
en disant,
êtes-vous encore
sans intelligence ?
Faites attention
au lévent des pharisiens.
L'un des plus grands
obstacles
pour notre compréhension
de la vraie théologie,
de la vérité
à propos de Dieu,
c'est l'attachement
avec les habitudes
de nos églises,
les enseignements
des traditions humaines
et de ne pas permettre
que la parole
des dieux
ait plus de poids
sur la formation
de notre compréhension
des dieux
que c'est
dont on a été habitué.
C'est très important.
Et donc,
Paul,
il a,
par expérience personnelle,
l'expérience puissante
de sa conversion,
il a eu
un saut énorme
en termes
de théologie.
Et quelqu'un
a déjà dit ça,
certaines personnes
qui ont eu,
je pense que c'est
John Favelle
lorsqu'il partage
son témoignage
d'expérience
de réveil avec Dieu,
qui était déjà
un grand théologien,
à la fin de cette expérience
il dit,
c'est comme si
cette expérience
avait surmonté
dans ma capacité
de comprendre Dieu
des dizaines
de livres de théologie.
Et donc,
c'est clair,
si la théologie,
elle est là
pour nous enseigner
les vérités
à propos de Dieu
et que l'objectif
central de Dieu
soit toujours
celui
que nous puissions
lui connaître,
les connaître
afin d'émener
en relation avec lui
car c'est une chose
de connaître
à propos de Dieu,
c'est une autre chose
de connaître Dieu.
Et la fonction
de la théologie
c'est toujours pratique,
c'est toujours relationnel,
c'est toujours
pour notre adoration.
Et l'impact
de la théologie
c'est tout simplement
si je suis conscient
que j'ai vu
que j'ai vu ma vie
devant ces dieux
et si ces dieux-là
agissent de cette manière
envers ces créatures,
ma théologie
aura un impact
direct
sur la manière
dont je vis.
Si je suis à la légère
par rapport à ma théologie,
je serai à la légère
par rapport à ma vie.
Donc quand on voit
la sanctification
des pôles
dans la pratique,
quand on voit
les services
des pôles
dans la pratique,
quelque part
ce sont des déclenchements
de sa connaissance
de Dieu.
Ce n'est pas
qu'il a tellement
fait pour Dieu
et par là
il a appris
beaucoup sur Dieu.
Non,
il faisait tellement
pour Dieu
car il connaissait
Dieu tellement bien.
Et donc la réalité
c'est que nous devons
considérer
que cette expérience
des conversions
de Paul
était une rencontre
avec Christ lui-même.
Les Christ
ressuscités
apparus à Paul
et il nous raconte
d'autres expériences
puissantes
qu'il a eues avec Dieu
et qui nous aident
à comprendre
comment il a pu avoir
une connaissance
si sublime des dieux
à point de pouvoir
nous laisser
des enseignements
à propos de ces dieux
qui soient si précis
et au même temps
si touchants,
si éclatants,
si profonds
en termes relationnels.
Mais non seulement
par l'expérience
personnelle
et puissante
ou surnaturelle
avec Dieu
mais on sait aussi
qu'Paul avait
un grand bagage
qui lui a projeté
vers l'avant.
Voici les douze
très simples
qui vivaient
avec Jésus-Christ.
Des pêcheurs
vissamples
qui travaillaient
de manière très simple
un collecteur d'impôts
et c'est intéressant
de les remarquer
que par ces groupes-là
il y a eu
beaucoup de progrès.
Quand on lit vraiment
les écrits
de tous les apôtres
dans le Nouveau Testament
ils sont tous inhérents
et ils sont tous capables
de nous faire contempler
la gloire de Dieu.
Mais c'est clair
que chez Paul
il y a quelque chose
qui va au-delà
à point
que Pierre lui-même
va reconnaître.
Il va reconnaître
que ce sont des écrits
saints
c'est-à-dire
que ce sont des écrits
inspirés
mais qu'il part
certains points
qui sont un peu compliqués.
Et donc par là
nous sommes en train de considérer
oui,
Paul avait un bagage
qui lui avait projeté
vers l'avant
car il a été formé
par Gamaliel
il connaissait énormément
bien les écritures
il était
l'un des mieux
éduqués
à cause
dans la connaissance
théologique
de l'Ancien Testament.
Et donc
quand cela devient
une connaissance personnelle
et qu'à partir
de cette expérience
avec Jésus
il va employer
ses capacités
dans l'étude
des écritures
quelque chose
que nous allons voir
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
quand il est emprisonné
en Rome
il écrit à Timothée
pour venir
l'apporter
d'entre autres choses
les perchements
et les livres.
Et par là
il veut continuer
ses études
coopérer
avec la grâce
des dieux
étudier
la théologie
jusqu'à la fin
de sa vie
un étant apôtre
lui-même
et comme on a considéré
dans cette lettre
il va
il va démontrer
un engagement
très diligent
aussi
donc là
c'est la description
de l'apostolat
de Paul
il va dire par exemple
au verset 17
du chapitre 1
qu'après avoir
cette révélation
du fils des dieux
qu'il appelait
envers les païens
il est parti
donc il n'est pas
allé voir directement
les apôtres
mais il est parti
vers l'Arabie
et c'est un consensus
dans les commentateurs
bibliques
qui c'est le plus probable
pendant cette période
qui a pu durer
trois ans
il était en train
d'étudier la parole
de Dieu
réformuler
sa compréhension
théologique
donc par là
nous voyons
comment
Paul
par l'emploi
de ses efforts
de ses capacités
il a coopéré
avec la grâce
de Dieu
pour la formation
de sa théologie
et quand on parle
nous devons parler
aussi de notre théologie
car c'est peut-être
celui qui a
les plus contribué
avec notre
compréhension théologique
je vais vous citer
James Dan
il dit le suivant
les faits
demeurent
que l'influence
et les écrits
de Paul
ont façonné
les christianistes
comme les écrits
ou la théologie
d'aucun autre individu
ne l'ont fait
si la théologie
est mesurée
en termes
d'articulation
de la croyance
chrétienne
alors les lettres
de Paul
ont jeté
les bases
de la théologie
chrétienne
qui n'a
jamais été
égalée
ou remplacée
d'où aussi
l'affirmation
qu'il y a
les plus grands
théologiens
chrétiens
de tous les temps
les statuts
de Paul
dans les canons
du Nouveau Testament
en soi
donnent
aux écrits
théologiques
de Paul
une prééminence
qui éclipse
tous les théologiens
chrétiens
qui l'ont suivi
quand on voit
vraiment
comment Paul
a excellé
dans la théologie
je vais vous citer
un autre
historicien
Philippe Schaff
il dit le suivant
remarquez par les écrits
de Paul
quelle expérience
nous avons
avec la théologie
enflammée de Paul
il dit
sa logique est en feu
il régorge
d'arguments
habiles
d'antithèses
courageuses
d'assauts
impétueux
des transitions
brusques
des virages
soudaines
des zigzags
questions
exclamations
soutenantes
il est dialectique
et argumentatif
il aime la logique
les phrases paradoxales
et les jeux
des mots
il résonne à partir
de l'écriture
des prémices
des conclusions
il pousse
la diversaire
au mur
sans pitié
et les réduit
à l'absurde
mais sans se préoccuper
des personnalités
il est familier
avec les âmes
tranchantes
du ridicule
de l'ironie
du sarcasme
mais les tient
en échec
et les utilise
rarement
il varie
l'argumentation
en touchant
les appels
au cœur
et éclat
d'éloquence
des anges
il n'est jamais
sec
ou énuyeux
et ne gaspille
jamais
ces mots
il est bref
qu'on scie
et frappe
dans la mille
son laconisme
les rend parfois
obscurs
ses paroles
sont comme
des guerriers
marchant
vers la victoire
et la paix
ils sont comme
entourant
des montagnes
se précipitant
dans des rapides
écumants
au-dessus
des précipices
puis coulant
calmément
sur des vertes
prairies
ou comme
un orage
se terminant
par une averse
rafraîchissante
et un soleil
radieux
Paul a créé
les vocabulaires
de la théologie
scientifique
et mis une
signification
plus profonde
en termes religieux
et moraux
qu'ils n'ont
jamais eu avant
nous ne pouvons
pas parler
des péchés
chères
grâces
miséricordes
paix
rédemption
expiation
justification
glorification
église
foi
amour
sans témoigner
de l'effet
ineffaçable
que les plus grands
des rabbins juifs
et des anciens
chrétiens
a eu
sur la langue
de la chrétienté
voilà la contribution
théorique de Paul
voilà pourquoi
nous avons
la plupart
du contenu
du Nouveau Testament
c'était un homme
qui a
un homme
qui a pris sa vie
ses efforts
son passé
son présent
et il a
diligemment
consacré
aux études
de la parole
des dieux
de la théologie
et donc bien sûr
que nous avons
des hommes
dans l'histoire
qui sont
très simples
dans leur connaissance
et dans leur capacité
de nous expliquer
Dieu
et la théologie
comme
Bounian
Moudi
ou la plupart
des apôtres
chrétiens
mais
pour ce qui
concerne Paul
c'est extraordinaire
de remarquer
cette capacité
qu'il a eue
de développer
des concepts
qui puissent
nous communiquer
citant des grâces
et des précisions
dans la connaissance
des dieux
et quand je pense
un peu
à Paul
et surtout
quand Pierre
il fait
cette remarque
par rapport
à la difficulté
de certains
de ses écrits
je dois me rappeler
en fait
qu'il écrivait
je dois vous rappeler
au plus simple
aux esclaves
et donc bien sûr
qu'il y a des termes
qui sont un peu
étrangers pour nous
un peu anciens
un peu très techniques
mais ce ne sont pas
des termes
que Dieu puisse considérer
inatteinables
inaccessibles
pour son peuple
nous sommes
dans la majorité
sauvés
tous
simples
des compréhensions
et en même temps
nous avons reçu
une capacité
et la parole
des dieux
qui veut qu'on garde
toujours la foi
comme des enfants
mais qui ne veut jamais
qu'on reste infantile
et pour plus
qu'on ne puisse pas
nous développer
dans toutes les connaissances
qui se montrent à développer
Dieu nous assure
que nous pouvons
nous développer
dans les champs
de connaissances
les plus importants
la connaissance des dieux
qui aura des implications
pour toutes
c'est pour ça que la Bible
nous considère
comme la lumière du monde
pour plus simple qu'on soit
si nous sommes chrétiens
nous sommes la lumière du monde
et nous devons nous exercer
à nous élever
je me rappelle
que pour Achille a raconté
un jour
qu'il est allé partager
un peu
dans une église
avec les enfants
et il a posé la question
si quelqu'un connaissait
la doctrine
de la propitiation
et il considérait
que c'était un terme
très technique
et un enfant
je pense 7 ans
a levé la main
et a répondu parfaitement
à la question
et ce sont des choses
qu'on doit se poser
est-ce qu'on serait
à la mesure de répondre
ou par exemple
Lloyd-Jones
qui quand il était
à la fin de son ministère
qu'il était malade
il a reçu une lettre
à l'hôpital
et quand il a lu
c'était d'une fille
de 10 ans
qui disait
reviens s'il te plaît
au pupitre
si tu es le seul
pasteur que j'arrive
à comprendre
et donc quand on donne
des excuses
par rapport à la difficulté
à la longueur
d'un serment
des termes techniques
la question qu'on doit se poser
est-ce que c'est pas
plutôt la paresse
est-ce que c'est pas plutôt
mon attachement
à ma vision personnelle
des dieux
est-ce que c'est pas plutôt
de ne pas vouloir
être confronté
par la réalité
par la vérité biblique
et nous devrions chérir
cette réalité
de la théologie
car les doctrines
déterminent
l'expérience
des vies
qu'on aura
la connaissance
des dieux
et donc voici
les modèles pour nous
qu'est-ce que nous faisons
de nos questions
de ces travails
continuels
préventifs
par rapport
à la connaissance biblique
est-ce que nous sommes
en train d'étudier
la Bible constamment
est-ce que nous sommes
en train
de faire
usage
d'autres recours
d'autres professeurs
chrétiens
des personnes
qui ont écrit
des livres
théologiques
pour nous aider
à comprendre
est-ce que nous sommes
là
préoccupés
avec les choses
qu'on lise
avec les recours
qui nous sont présentés
est-ce qu'on vérifie
dans la parole de Dieu
si ce qui nous a
enseigné
est biblique
est-ce qu'on demande
au pasteur
s'il peut nous suggérer
une lecture
est-ce qu'on s'exerce
dans cette ère
des connaissances
qui est la plus importante
pour notre vie
l'une des choses
principales
qui vont rester
pour toute l'éternité
pour nous
et que nous pouvons
commencer à faire
aujourd'hui
et donc connaître
la théologie
répondre
vivre
pour Jean
il va faire référence
à ces crises
qui Paul a dû traverser
et nous voyons
que ces crises sont là
quand Paul va parler
de la prédestination
il ne va pas cacher
qu'il s'agit
d'une doctrine difficile
à comprendre
mais il ne peut pas
se cacher
d'une vérité biblique
si on lit
Romain 9
par exemple
ce sont les démonstrations
des plus grandes crises
de l'apôtre Paul
la première
de savoir
que ses compatriotes
seraient perdus
elle dit
je préférerais
moi-même être perdu
séparé du Christ
pour qu'il soit sauvé
mais pour plus
que mon désir personnel
c'est que tout mon peuple
ethnique soit sauvé
ce n'est pas la vérité
et je ne peux pas
me cacher de la vérité
mais la crise
elle est là
dans le cœur d'épaule
et ensuite
il va faire
cette crise
se développer
par rapport à la doctrine
de la prédestination
est-ce que l'ouvrage
peut dire
à celui qu'il a fait
pourquoi tu m'as fait attention
à la fin
c'est la souveraineté
de Dieu
la réponse
tout va finir
et aboutir
dans la défense
de la justice
de Dieu
dans tout ce qu'il fait
de la gloire
de Dieu
dans tout ce qu'il fait
dans le fait
que sa grâce
va ressortir
les plus
d'entre toute autre
vertu de Dieu
dans sa communication
avec les êtres morts
tout sera résolu
tout trouvera
une solution
mais Paul ne va jamais
cacher
que certaines crises
sont légitimes
sont réelles
ils sont là
sauf que nous ne pouvons pas
éviter les crises
en nous enfouillant
de la Bible
de la vérité
et donc nous devrions
faire face
aux doctrines
les plus difficiles
pour nous
et nous équiper
pour connaître Dieu
pour réjouir
de sa présence
ensuite
Paul est un modèle
non seulement
des coopérations
avec les Saint-Esprits
pour ceux qui concernent
sa théologie
mais aussi
pour ceux qui concernent
l'évangélisation
Paul en tant qu'évangéliste
donc ici au verset 2
il dit clairement
Paul apôtre
non de la part des hommes
des séants
ni par un homme
mais par Jésus Christ
et Dieu le Père
qui l'a ressuscité des morts
et verset 2
et tous les frères
qui sont avec moi
aux églises
de la Galatie
donc tous les frères
qui sont avec moi
les plus progrès
c'est qu'ils fassent référence
aux membres
de l'église d'Antioche
qui sont là avec lui
lorsqu'il est en train d'écrire
donc il est connecté
à une église
c'est Antioche
qui a envoyé
Paul et Barnabas
pour son premier voyage
missionnaire
donc les fruits
sont les églises
de la Galatie
on peut penser
à l'istre
d'herbe
l'Ikaoni
donc si nous revenons
à actes chapitre 13
jusqu'au chapitre 16
nous allons comprendre
comment Paul a implanté
ces églises
et ce qui est intéressant
à remarquer
c'est tout d'abord
qu'un évangéliste
selon la Bible
n'est pas la conception
que nous avons aujourd'hui
des missionnaires
missionnaire
n'est pas en termes bibliques
et malheureusement
on a des conceptions
des missionnaires
qui sont là en train
de faire des croisades
évangélistiques
ou qui sont là
en train de faire
tout simplement
l'évangélisation individuelle
mais ce qui est important
à remarquer
c'est qu'un évangéliste
c'était une caractéristique
si on peut dire comme ça
prééminente
particulièrement
de l'apôtre
et Paul
en tant qu'apôtre
donc à nouveau
il a excellé aussi
car une grâce
surabondante
était sur lui
mais on ne peut pas
oublier
les efforts
que Paul a employés
pour coopérer
avec la grâce de Dieu
et nous devons considérer
en fait
comment il a pu faire
toutes ces vrais-là
on doit se rappeler
il a été élevé
à Tarsus
c'était une ville
portuaire
très importante
il avait
plus ou moins
trois citoyennetés
il avait au moins
deux citoyennetés
la Romaine
et la citoyenneté
juive
et au même temps
il était
complètement capable
dans les domaines grecs
donc quand on voit
l'usage conscient
de tous ces recours
à l'occasion
de son ministère
nous voyons
un Paul
qui était conscient
de ses capacités
et qui ne négligeait pas
l'importance
de l'utiliser
de s'engager
dans l'évangélisation
mais ce qui est important
à remarquer
c'est qu'il est là
quelque part
sous la supervision
et quelque part
rédévable
aux anciens
de l'église
des Antioches
donc quand vous voyez
les conceptions
des apôtres
aujourd'hui
qui ne doivent
rendre compte
devant personne
qui pensent
qu'ils sont
les autorités
sublimes
de l'univers
la réalité
c'est que
quand on apprend
avec Paul
il a été envoyé
par une église
il reconnaît
l'autorité
de cette ambassade
qui a l'église
à Antioche
qui va l'envoyer
donc il était
quelque part
un superviseur
mais aussi
connecté
à une église locale
et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que
la centralité
de l'église locale
était quelque chose
d'essentiel
nous ne pouvons pas
penser
à membre d'église
à quelqu'un
qui s'est converti
sans être connecté
à une église locale
dans le Nouveau Testament
voici ce qu'il dit
Robert Raymond
à propos de Paul
c'est peu accidentel
que Paul
ne se visualisait pas
autant
qu'un briquetier
en vrac
mais plutôt
comme un constructeur
des bâtiments
sa mission
a été toujours
centrée
dans des accomplissements
corporatifs
une dimension
distinctive
de la mission
Pauline
c'est qu'elle
ne retrouve pas
son sens
plan
ou sa conformité
ni dans une croisade
des prédications
journalistiques
ni seulement
dans les conversions
individuelles
mais uniquement
dans la présence
des églises
fermement établies
bien sûr
qu'il faisait
des évangélisations
personnelles
on les voit
publiquement
en Athènes
on les voit
publiquement
un peu partout
en implantant des églises
mais son objectif
c'est que
ces évangélisations
personnelles
aboutissent toujours
dans la formation
d'une église
ou des personnes
qui pouvaient
se connecter
à une église locale
donc là
c'est un Paul
qui nous allons trouver
les bases
les plus évidentes
les plus précises
et les plus éclatantes
pour les missions
pour les missions globales
pour l'évangélisation locale
et pour l'évangélisation globale
et donc là
nous devrions aussi
coopérer
chacun d'entre nous
de manière individuelle
avec ses services
nous sommes tous appelés
à faire des disciples
à participer
dans l'évangélisation
en tant qu'église
bien sûr
en tant qu'individu
et la réalité
c'est que
d'évangéliser
de partager
la bonne nouvelle
n'est pas
une tâche
réservée
tout simplement
à ceux
qui vont être appelés
de manière spéciale
pour se consacrer
à temps plein
pour cette oeuvre
mais c'est un appel
pour tous les membres
à nouveau
il est un repère
pour nous tous
même s'il est un repère
plus intensif
plus consacré
et nous sommes tous là
appelés par Dieu
à nous consacrer
et à suivre ces modèles
comment pourriez-vous
mieux vous équiper
par l'aide des anciens
pour que pendant la semaine
vous ayez la possibilité
de créer des opportunités
et de faire de l'évangélisation
comment nous faisons
usage
de l'église locale
pour contribuer
à notre équipage
à cet égard
et donc on voit clairement
comment Paul
il a été
un modèle
de coopération
avec la grâce
rédemptrice
donc cette rédemption
du Saint-Esprit
qui a travaillé
dans la vie de Paul
et qui a traversé
la vie de Paul
pour porter
la rédemption
à d'autres personnes
à d'autres nations
c'est important
de remarquer
combien intentionnel
était Paul
dans sa vie
pour servir
à l'évangélisation
conscient
de ses capacités
jamais esclave
d'une seule méthode
il n'était pas partout
avec les quatre lois
spirituelles par exemple
il était
en train de considérer
son public
comme en Athènes
il va citer
par exemple
même leur
leur poète
il va avoir
la conscience
de quelle était
leur religion
on va considérer
qu'il était
faible avec les faibles
fort avec les forts
afin de gagner
les faibles
les forts
je me suis fait
tout
donc il était
comme s'il était
sous la loi
avec ceux qui sont
comme s'il n'était
pas sous la loi
avec ceux qui ne sont
donc Paul va dire
je me suis fait
tout à tous
afin de sauver
de toute manière
quelques-uns
j'ai fait tout
à cause de l'évangile
afin d'y avoir part
et donc c'est
très important
il n'a jamais perdu
son authenticité
pour embrasser
cette stratégie
d'évangélisation
il n'a jamais
embrassé
une stratégie
d'évangélisation
qui ne soit pas
biblique
il n'est pas
allé chercher
chez les diables
c'est qu'attire
plus les personnes
pour vouloir
attirer les personnes
vers Christ
et donc
sans jamais
perdre l'authenticité
ni changer
son message
sans jamais
compromettre
l'évangile
c'est ce qu'il va dire
au grand tien
en disant
lorsque je suis allé
chez vous
ce n'est pas
avec une supériorité
des langages
ou des sagesses
que je suis allé
vous annoncer
les témoignages
des dieux
car je n'ai pas
eu la pensée
de savoir
parmi vous
autre chose
que Jésus Christ
et celui-ci
crucifié
moi j'étais auprès
de vous
dans un état
de faiblesse
des craintes
et des grands tremblements
et ma parole
et ma prédication
ne reposaient pas
sur mes discours
persuasifs
de la sagesse
mais sur la démonstration
d'esprit
et de puissance
afin que votre foi
fût fondée
non sur la sagesse
des hommes
mais sur la puissance
des dieux
c'est pour ça
que Paul
n'avait jamais
compromis
l'évangile
il n'était
rédévable
à personne
quelque part
c'est très intéressant
car il va dire ici
dans la lettre
au Galate
qu'il n'est pas là
pour plaire
les personnes
et il va dire
que moi-même
sois en athème
si je vous présente
un autre évangile
et donc
c'est pas
pour profit personnel
il était authentique
vis-à-vis au message
et donc
il était finalement
l'un des plus grands
repères
en termes d'effort
il dit qu'il a
servi plus
que tous les autres apôtres
toutefois
Dieu
à travers lui
et non lui-même
mais de toute manière
il était là
en train de servir
plus que tous les autres
en souffrance
on n'a pas le temps
de voir
mais vous pouvez revenir
sur 12e Corinthiens 12
pour les voir
et le fait
qu'il s'appelle
un acte 9
nous voyons déjà
que les seigneurs
lui appelaient
carrément pour souffrir
à cause de l'évangile
donc on voit
les souffrances
les renoncements
personne ne les surpasse
en ces termes-là
toutes celles qu'il a rénoncé
tous ceux qui l'a souffert
pour l'évangile
c'est ça l'évangélisation aussi
c'est pas
choisir les styles de vie
qui s'adaptent plus
à mon confort
ou la loi
du moins grand effort
donc
les chrétiens
ils savent
qu'il grise
à payer un prix
pour lui
très élevé
et la moindre chose
qu'on puisse faire
c'est de rendre
un culte rédévable
en présentant nos vies
comme sacrifice
et donc
ça fait un peu peur
quand on voit
la souffrance
de l'apôtre Paul
et qu'on voit
tous les glamours
qui tournent autour
aujourd'hui
de l'idée
d'être une célébrité
gospel
et des personnes
qui sont attirées
pour devenir
des anciens
des pasteurs
car ils voient
un modèle
d'anciens des pasteurs
qui sont surtout
ou toujours
en train de profiter
des meilleures choses
de cette vie
il faut voir
en fait
quelles sont
les détresses
qu'ils ont déjà traversées
quelles sont
les tribulations
qu'ils ont déjà endurées
il faut considérer
qu'ils seront persécutés
c'est un modèle
pour
les apôtres
c'est un modèle
pour Timothée
parce que Paul veut
renouveler la foi
ou la fermeté
de Timothée
il dit
souffre avec moi
c'est ça son appel
et c'est la même chose
pour tous les chrétiens
Paul il va nous dire clairement
tous ceux qui veulent
mener une vie pieuse
seront persécutés
donc c'est
les modèles
des missionnaires
d'évangélistes
selon la Bible
et quels étaient
les résultats
donc bien sûr
attention
si les Saint-Esprit
nous assurent
que l'œuvre de Dieu
sera accomplie
il n'y a aucune autre
occupation
qu'on puisse faire
de notre vie
qui ait plus
d'espoir
des réussites
que d'emmengager
avec l'évangélisation
toute autorité
m'a été donnée
!
sur les ciels
et sur la terre
allez donc
faites les disciples
et j'essaierai avec vous
Jésus nous a dit ça
donc la réalité
c'est que
pour tout autre projet
personnel de vie
nous n'avons aucune assurance
que nous allons réussir
à ce qu'on aimerait réussir
mais quand on s'engage
et qu'on fait
de nos vies
nos vocations
particulières
un moyen à travers
lesquels
nous allons accomplir
l'évangélisation
nous avons l'assurance
que si nous investissons
à ça
nous allons voir
les résultats
et ça
c'est super encourageant
la souveraineté
des dieux
dans l'évangélisation
et nous voyons
comment Paul
a eu conscience
de ça
et même s'il devait
traverser la souffrance
il savait
que cela
porterait des fruits
Grecian Mackin
il dit
les mouvements chrétiens
en 35
après Jésus Christ
aurait semblé
à un observatoire
superficiel
être une secte juive
quand un plus tard
c'était clairement
une religion mondiale
cet établissement
du christianisme
pour religion mondiale
dans une mesure
presque aussi grande
que n'importe quel
grand mouvement historique
peut être attribué
à un seul homme
fut l'oeuvre
de l'apôtre Paul
l'oeuvre des dieux
à travers l'apôtre Paul
qui s'est consacrée à ça
et qui a vu
donc les résultats
donc quel est
notre engagement
dans l'évangélisation
et pour conclure
Paul était
avant tout
un modèle
de coopération
avec l'oeuvre
rédemptrice
de Saint-Esprit
en tant que chrétien
si son rôle d'apôtre
c'était quelque part
ses capacités naturelles
plus élevées
la réalité
c'est que
servir Christ
en tant que missionnaire
évangéliste
ou développer
la théologie
avait un but
central
son plus grand plaisir
était
communion avec Jésus Christ
et plaire Dieu
à travers son service
donc à la base
Paul
ne serait
aucune chose d'autre
il ne pourrait
exceller dans
aucune autre chose
s'il n'était avant tout
tout simplement
un chrétien
quelqu'un
dont l'identité
est connectée
intimement
à Christ lui-même
nous voyons ça
dans la salutation
où son nom
va presque disparaître
comme nous sommes
en train de voir
et son attachement
à Christ ressort
quand on va
par toute autre lettre
de l'apôtre Paul
nous voyons
qu'il se considère
non seulement
en tant qu'apôtre
ici nous voyons
qui est apôtre
car c'est important
de remarquer
l'importance
pour corriger
la mauvaise conception
de cette église
mais dans toute autre lettre
dans la majorité
des autres lettres
nous allons trouver
sclave du Christ
servitueur du Christ
c'est quelqu'un
qui est accroché à Christ
sa vie
et accroché à lui
nous voyons cela
à cause de sa conversion
nous voyons en Philippiens
chapitre 3
la description
de sa conversion
il va comparer
toute sa réussite
païenne
séculaire
pas païenne
mais séculaire
séculaire
ou laïque
comparer
à la connaissance
du Christ
c'est la sublime
vocation pour lui
c'est de connaître
la gloire du Christ
d'avoir connu
les Christ
et quand on pense
à la manière
dont il a coopéré
à se conformer
avec Christ
tous les conseils
qui nous donne
dans la bataille
contre les péchés
il nous parle
de l'armure spirituelle
Romain 6 à 8
il nous parle
de la réussite
dans la bataille
contre la chair
les mondes
et les diables
et l'espoir
des victoires
si nous coopérons
avec le Saint-Esprit
et c'est ça un problème
car aujourd'hui
notre conception
des sanctifications
est toujours
dans la dépendance
nous voulons goûter
l'intimité avec Dieu
et nous voulons goûter
des progrès
en sanctification
par une expérience
soudaine
miraculeuse
surnaturelle
et la réalité
c'est que Paul
il était diligent
et constant
dans ses études
à propos de Dieu
dans sa connaissance
dans ses prières
et il était constant
aussi dans ses efforts
il réduisait
son corps
à la servitude
pour qu'en ayant
prêché à d'autres
il ne soit pas trouvé
désqualifié
c'est très intéressant
et c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
que par là
Paul
il est capable
de nous donner
les plus grands conseils
et il nous donne
les secrets
de sa réussite
qui traversent
énormément
des confrontations
de la chair
confronter
les premières
impuces
envers les péchés
c'est sanctifier
progressivement
continuellement
savoir se préparer
avant la tentation
savoir réagir
à la tentation
et savoir progresser
indépendamment
de la tentation
par une ambition
de se conformer
à Christ
lorsqu'il prie
pour les églises
et qu'il dit
que vous pouviez
vous présenter
devant Christ
avec vos mots
purs
et remplis
des fruits
de justice
il démontre
qu'elle est
sa plus grande ambition
c'est d'être trouvé
devant Jésus Christ
dans ses jours glorieux
avec nos mots
purs
lavé
et remplis
des fruits
de justice
l'air Dieu
intimité
avec Christ
et là
nous voyons ça
surtout
quand on considère
comment sa théologie
était pleine
d'affection
son service
était plein
d'affection
mais surtout
quand il écrit
aux Philippiens
en parlant
qu'il ne sait
même pas
à quoi choisir
s'il veut
mourir
et être
avec Christ
qui est incomparablement
mieux pour lui
car il est avant tout
un chrétien
tout simplement
quelqu'un
passionné
par Christ
mais si
il faut vivre
dans la chair
il le fera
car il sait
que son service
peut plaire aussi
Christ
vivre
c'est Christ
mourir
est un gant
et c'est là
dévoile
véritablement
quelqu'un
dont l'identité
essaie d'être
un chrétien
d'ailleurs
c'est par les ministères
des pôles
en Antioche
et pas par les ministères
des douze apôtres
mais pas
Paul
en Antioche
qui est
les disciples
ont été appelés
par la première fois
chrétiens
car avant tout
l'ambition de Paul
était d'être
un imitateur
du Christ
et ça devrait être
aussi notre ambition
et c'est en voulant
être un imitateur
du Christ
à pleine force
en coopérant
avec la grâce
rédemptrice
du Saint-Esprit
que nous pouvons
grandir dans notre théologie
grandir dans notre
évangélisation
et grandir
dans notre intimité
et conformité
avec Jésus Christ
Amen
les bons mots pour prier
et grandir dans notre
!